the public sector has a big
responsibility and that requires using
the right technology join us in historic
downtown Austin Texas as we talk to
soft-serve about how the public sector
has been adopting the cloud with Google
Cloud partners thanks for joining us
today Ron can you tell us a little more
about soft-serve sure absolutely
soft-serve is a curious company starting
about 26 years ago founded by some
rocket scientists and their PhD students
set out to solve problems in the data
world complex software issues and
systems that just didn't want to talk
and didn't want to play together company
is now pushing 10,000 people spread
around close to 30 delivery centers
across the globe so soft-serve is a
Google cloud partner what does that mean
for companies who choose to work with
soft-serve sure well it means a few
things it means that we have Best of
Breed technologies to work with it means
that we've got several hundred certified
people on Google cloud it means that we
work hand in glove with GCP to be
certain that our clients are getting the
best of both worlds not just technology
for technology's sake but technology for
the people's sake and making sure that
those pieces of technology are delivered
in concert with the end goal and that
end goal is determined in concert how
does this look for the public sector
well the public sector is its own animal
as we all know right they have a very
big responsibility and the
responsibility is to the lives of the
people their constituents right what
happens on the roadway is what happens
in the buildings what happens in the
communities and when they look into into
technology solutions they tend to be
limited because of that lens so bringing
in somebody like an outside partner like
a soft-serve to work with technologies
that these municipalities know they need
or the public sector in general knows
they need or suspects they may need
sometimes it puts them in a position of
really being able to stay focused on
what their mission is while outsourcing
to us to be able to come in and give
them really expert advice that's a
really great way to put it and one of
those example for technologies is the
cloud sure what does that look like for
soft-serve depart
with these public sector entities and
then look at implementing things in the
cloud
sure so there is the initial reticence
the challenges that go with what it's
not mine it's not in my four walls I
don't have a team of people to manage it
but shortly behind that comes the
realization that you really don't have
control over this there are employees
who are using their own devices that are
accessing personal accounts that are
doing their shopping and whatever else
and so you do have outside influence on
your own network but then you get into
the costs of supporting these massive
server farms that you'd need to support
connected and autonomous vehicles
connected devices to the environment
there's the scale that you need to be
able to operate with and and that and so
when you start considering these things
and you think about your public sector
responsibility to be frugal while being
responsible it makes a lot of sense to
move to the cloud and really look into
how you can do that one of the things we
really like to do is focus in on
assessments and making sure that those
assessments result in a plan and Google
cloud is very much in sync with that
well thanks so much for coming in Rahn
and telling us about how soft-serve
helps enable companies including the
public sector to really understand and
do more with their data sure I
appreciate the opportunity thank you
thanks for watching and stay tuned as we
talk more about the technology behind
building a smart city with soft sir
you